what you got Air Force nuns whacks
[Laughter]
[Music]
you guys ever been to a Sneaker Con or
any shoe convention I would like to be
invited
yeah so at Seeker con there's like a
regulation they say they don't allow
gambling of any type when you run like
your boots or stuff like that yet
Sneaker Con itself runs this 300 sneaker
Mystery Box thing where you pay 300
bucks and you don't know what's in the
box you don't know what shoe you're
getting that's a lot of money for not
knowing right but is it always a good
shoe though I've bought mystery box for
like five grand two what the [__] it's
usually working show them your kicks
right now show them what they
everybody show their kicks right now
show the heat show the heat Ryan what
you got on palladium boots that are
retail that I don't 50 bucks Harley we
got them Chucks I don't know don't skip
over to collab oh undefeated Chucks
that's dope what you got Air Force nuns
whacks
buddy now everybody show your ears
I don't wanna I don't like this game
what are you working with audio
and then we'll get there everybody
whisper so see who can hear it huh
I can hear fine okay what color belts
y'all got huh
where's your Rainbow Crocs you always
wear I didn't wear them today bro you
always wear them right now I didn't wear
them today you know 7-Eleven in Crocs
did a collab it just popped up on my
feet oh because my girl and I
anniversary what came in your five
thousand dollar Mystery Box yeah yeah
what'd you get yeah what came in their
mystery about us five thousand dollars a
lot of shoes
yeah yeah yeah I'm so bad
I
I bought one from some other reseller
was it worth the 5 000 yeah I mean I
made like 6 500. oh that's retired so so
your purpose of buying shoes is to
resell that is like your main thing yeah
well I mean I did used to always like I
just couldn't afford it like a lot of
people and then now that I can and I'm
like oh there's money yeah [__] those
regular people yeah yeah
I got annoyed that there was resellers
like everybody else so then I was like
[__] I'm just gonna join them yeah oh
that's good you're a good person
good Arc good Village you know I [__]
hate those six chapters but okay it's a
lot of money in it a lot of money
I'm just kidding imagine tape talk to
you let's go double down double down
what's the problem with sneakercon doing
these 300 boxes uh what were people so
pissed about because everybody got mad
at it so this is Crocs they don't
actually do it themselves there's
another company that runs it it's
another store I think it's like I forgot
what I think I sent it to you I forgot
their name
um but there's another store and then
they just made a whole bunch of mystery
box that they said it was worth 300 but
they're really not there's like two or
three shoes out of like the 50 boxes
that is an actual so people getting Duds
huh yeah so in your case like when you
buy a mystery box from these reputable
guys you know you're getting kind of
value but you just don't know what shoes
yeah so most of the time when I buy it I
have to I make sure like it's at least
15 to 20 like profit for me because
they're giving me stuff that I don't
know what's in there and it could be
something that they can't sell so and I
can possibly sell because I'm in La so
where do you sell it I saw an Instagram
so the way that like mystery boxes work
though they'll be like hey I'm gonna
sell you this thing for 5 000 bucks you
don't know what kind of shoe you're
gonna get but it's around 5 000 in value
do you know that or sometimes it's like
surprise it's 20 bucks worth uh well
yeah that's why I have to vet whoever
I'm buying it from oh so if I don't know
you I won't buy it from you or I'll have
you send it to me first and I'll pay you
afterwards if I think it's getting the
value what I was at a mystery box well I
I'm still taking the mystery boxes I
don't know what it is but as long as
there's about like at least whatever I
paid for then I'll give you your money
but that's only what people that trust
me too with the money right yeah right
don't you behave yourself an offer up
though offer up people are so sketch
dude this is what I hate about people
unaffordable you'll put something up
right like let's say this is worth 700
right we go seven hundred dollars this
is what is worth blah blah blah somebody
like hey 25 cash today I'm like what
like how the [__] is that enticing to me
but I got the cash right now it's 25
though why the [__] would I sell this to
you you would love this one dude he
pulls this thing like he'll list
something and when someone lowballs him
he'll go all right why not here's the
address they pull up to the address and
they go what should I do it it is all
come inside and they're like to the
comedy club and he goes yeah then go on
stage and tell them your jokes
because I always resell gear all the
time and there's always somebody who low
balls but they're always full of [__]
right so like I just saw the camera
recently and then this person like
lowballed by like two grand I'm like God
damn cause I was selling the camera I
sold it to a fan actually and I gave it
to a really good price because he's a
fan so I'm like well [__] if it's a fan
I'll give it to him for super cheap but
the other person I was selling it to
they're like it was a 30 I was selling
for 3 900. after tax everything else the
whole package is worth about six grand
so it's a really good deal and the guy
was like
I'll give you a thousand for it I'm like
I was like I don't think you understand
how this works you have to give me
something reasonable that I'll actually
bite on right that like you buy horrible
1600 cash I'll get it today I just like
all right dude but what would it have
been otherwise when they say cash I'm
like what other things
I would actually prefer it like in any
other thing besides cash like I don't
need the [__] dude you know that
guy's texting you thing he's like dude
I'm the [__] Wolf of Wall Street dog
he's just a [__] up depending on now
yeah depending on the circumstance
sometimes it works on 16. in my case
last week I got the steal of the decade
for steal of a deal huh yeah because uh
like of several years back I own this
keyboard a motif xs8 and it was four
thousand dollars retail at the time I
had to sell it in a pinch when I needed
money back in the day and then I
recently found it again it might even be
the same keyboard
yeah but then but the guy was like it's
such an obscure specific thing yeah that
not everyone's gonna be searching for an
out of date specific old model keyboard
but then if it's just like a thing that
everyone still uses now that's very
general like yeah don't blowball that
yeah yeah yeah yeah some people just
have really odd etiquette when they sell
things like for example like if you're
trying to buy a camera right there'll be
a previous model but the new model is
the same price it's on the old model for
and then I'll be like I'll just message
them I was like hey not to not to be
disrespectful but literally this camera
the new one just came out why are you
selling it for retail for the same price
as a new one yeah right and they go like
well it's not it hasn't been used and
I'm like so is the new one I don't
understand the argument here and they're
like well it's going to be gone you
don't get it it's a new 2017 Toyota
Camry it's a brand new 1998 Honda Civic
dude come on now so if you were to buy a
mystery box or something at a specific
value don't you think it should at least
be worth that value well usually they
tell you they'll be like hey this is a
500 mystery box but you pay 200 to get
500 worth of stuff okay that's even
better I thought mystery boxes were just
gambling like you could get a Sriracha
[__] bottle or you can I mean it is
gambling but they usually guarantee the
amount of value in the Box yeah that's
the stupid thing is that sneakercon
doesn't allow gambling yet when this guy
explained the business model he goes
gambling it's a gamble yeah he said the
exact words it's a Gamble one of my
favorite if you go on YouTube shorts and
you see people uh haggling like shoe
stuff right like oh I got this shoe for
whatever the comments are the best
because all comments are then making fun
of people in the video they're like
younger shoes but nothing you can dress
why don't you spend that money on
[__] proactive with your acne it kind
of stuff it's getting roasted
Amphitheater of haters yeah because when
you go to these Sneaker Con things right
most people don't look like you they're
they're typically you're a handsome man
dude I [__] you so we all win for the
record yes
[Laughter]
they'll have like the nicest shoe right
but the outfit is trash the the [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she spent it
all on the shoes they're wearing bales
of hay
and like the way they describe their
shoe like they'll be like oh where'd you
get those shoes how much did it cost I
spent about six racks on it yeah and
then like you're just waiting for people
in the comments to make fun of you and
it's just literally them tearing this
person apart the whole six racks and 50
cents on their burlap sack of a dress I
mean but that reflects so closely and
when you see like a Crown Vic with like
three thousand dollar Rings you know
it's like the same thing it's like why
would you do that because it's sick as
[__] I feel like this like priorities if
you're buying shoes to resell I think
that's dope because it's a business
right
um and then the other side too it's like
if you have shoes just make sure you
have any something else to go along with
it you know what I mean yeah it's like
this this is [__] weird like you're
wearing Air Mags or like ten thousand
dollar shoes what's the point of that
[__] and like what the [__] are you
gonna match with Air Max
what the [__] I took my one wheel do you
have a Air Max no I don't that's like 10
no 20 grand yeah I like how reasonable
you are that's really it I've slowly
started to like get rid of all my
expensive shoes because all the gr shoes
look nice
is there a good Financial return in very
expensive shoes or do you more mostly do
like bulk of a reasonable price I mean
when I buy my use like I buy my personal
shoes I buy them used so it's cheaper
and they're gonna wear them anyways yeah
and then I wear them and then I'm like
okay I'm sick of these then I just sell
them again and get my money back so it's
like I'm renting them or leasing them
that's right how much how much money
just to give us a scale how much money
moves per month within your sneaker
business uh before coven a lot more but
right now I've always a good month
uh I think probably like 10K in that
month oh 10k of sneakers uh being sold
to profit yeah wow 10K profit so how
much in total like 20 30k movies uh that
year I think it was like in profit I
think probably like 40K
um but and it's cash too so you know
that's sweet I do know
[Laughter]
was the roof the rain on me I don't know
those video clips of him with like a
bucket of water or a [__] TNT
you jump I pulled
but that year was like 100k in total
that's awesome that's a lot of work
though uh yeah at first it was a lot of
work but I was like people are just
coming to me at the bowling alley so all
I had to do was go outside oh that's
perfect man yeah right because if I
didn't have that like my friend was
doing it with me but he works in Sony
and he has to go to his office all the
time and he can't meet up with people
until after work and some people you
should have just brought him a Sony
did you ever get into like watches and
stuff because people would buy and sell
one yeah I had guys that are like do you
want to get into Rolexes and stuff like
that and I was like that's a lot of
money I was a little too scared I mean
you're already moving like 10 G's 20 30
40 G's yeah but that's from like 100 to
like 500 shoes that's small margins and
then that one is like the clientele for
shoes is [__] huge too it's like
ridiculous and it's Global like right
it's just a matter of like how much do
you want to make you know it got worse
because China and us
that stuff is affected a lot really yeah
in what way so I used to have a lot of
virus in Asia but now they're not buying
because they're protesting
so they're all protesting America no
they're just busy they're out busy
protesting I think it's Nike
it you know the whole Nike uh were many
brands that were using like you know uh
the uh uyghur oh yeah yeah yeah okay
labor shoes are so weird though a lot of
it's based on hype rather than what
people enjoy right so for example I got
these uh these Air Max 90s they're these
uh they were called the Watermelons
right General release and it was it was
such a basic shoe I didn't really enjoy
it but it matched these swim trunks that
I had so I got it it was really quick
that she was worth like 500 bucks I
bought this [__] for 90 dollars wow it
was it was it was such a general release
that almost everybody but nobody bought
it so nobody gave a [__] about it I just
checked the price recently because I was
like I don't want these shoes I'll see
what I can sell it for it's like worth
like 500 600 bucks like why nobody
wanted these [__] things but just
because it's now it's a rare commodity
it's non-existent anymore remember those
Air Max picnics the one that you
introduced me to I bought three pairs I
[__] Turf two of them I have one left
that's just worth like 600 bucks now
what if the guy who bought those shoes
you're like why do you want these These
are yo I got these slid trucks right
yeah
save color scheme
you're going to Hawaii
I wore them once in Hawaii and I never
wore them again
and you see a YouTube short video of him
matching us yeah
YouTube short comments
look at this [__] Kim Jong-un [__]
yeah you know those shoes while your
people are starving
I'm opening right now you didn't even
got a life vest
matching floaties dog no booty
Boogie wax
[Music]